The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's start.
So we are going to change
perspective again and think
in terms of lattice models.
So for the first
part of this course,
I was trying to change
your perspective
from thinking in terms of
microscopic degrees of freedom
to a statistical field.
Now we are going to go back
and try to build pictures
around things that
look more microscopic.
Typically, in many solid
state configurations,
we are dealing with transitions
that take place on a lattice.
For example, imagine a square
lattice, which is easy to draw,
but there could be all kinds
of cubic and more complex
lattices.
And then, at each
side of this lattice,
you may have one microscopic
degrees of freedom
that is ultimately participating
in the ordering and the phase
transition that
you have in mind.
Could, for example,
be a spin, or it
could be one atom
in a binary mixture.
And what you would like to do
is to construct a partition
function, again, by summing
over all degrees of freedom.
And we need some
kind of Hamiltonian.
And what we are going
to assume governs
that Hamiltonian is the analog
of this locality assumption
that we have in
statistical field theories.
That is, we are going
to assume that one
of our degrees of
freedom essentially
talks to a small
neighborhood around it.
And the simplest
neighborhood would
be to basically talk to
the nearest neighbor.
So if I, for example,
assign index i
to each side of
the lattice, let's
say I have some variable at each
side that could be something.
Let's call it SI.
Then my partition
function would be
obtained by summing
over all configurations.
And the weight I'm going to
assume in terms of this lattice
picture to be a sum
over interactions
that exist between
pairs of sides.
So that's already an assumption
that it's a pairwise thing.
And I'm going to use this
symbol ij with an angular
bracket along it,
around it, to indicate
the sum over nearest neighbors.
And there is some
function of the variables
that live on these neighbors.
So basically, in the
picture that I have drawn,
interactions exist only between
the places that you see lines.
So that this pin
does not interact
with this pin, this
pin, or this pin,
but it interacts
with these four pins,
to which it is near neighbor.
Now clearly, the form
of the interaction
has to be dictated by
your degrees of freedom.
And the idea of
this representation,
as opposed to the previous
statistical field theory
that we had, is that in
several important instances,
you may want to know not only
what these universal properties
are, but also, let's say, the
explicit temperature or phase
diagram of the system as a
function of external parameters
as well as temperature.
And if you have some idea of
how your microscopic degrees
of freedom interact
with each other,
you should be able to solve
this kind of partition function,
get the singularities,
et cetera.
So let's look at some simple
versions of this construction
and gradually discuss
the kinds of things
that we could do with it.
So some simple models.
The simplest one
is the Ising model
where the variable that
you have at each side
has two possibilities.
So it's a binary variable in
the context of a binary alloy.
It could be, let's
say, atom A or atom
B that is occupying
a particular site.
There are also cases
where there will be some--
if this is a surface and
you're absorbing particles
on top of it, there could be
a particle sitting here or not
sitting here.
So that would be also another
example of a binary variable.
So you could indicate that by
empty or occupied, zero or one.
But let's indicate it by
plus or minus one as the two
possible values
that you can have.
Now, if I look at the
analog of the interaction
that I have between two
sites that are neighboring
each other, what
can I write down?
Well, the most general
thing that I can write down
is, first of all, a
constant I can put,
such as shift of energy.
There could be a linear
term in-- let's put
all of these with minus signs.
Sigma i and sigma j.
I assume that it is symmetric
with respect to the two sides.
For reasons to become
apparent shortly,
I will divide by z, which
is the coordination number.
How many bonds per side?
And then the next
term that I can
put is something like
j sigma i sigma j.
And actually, I can't
put anything else.
Because if you s of this as
a power series in sigma i
and sigma j, and sigma
has only two values,
it will terminate here.
Because any higher power of
sigma is either one or sigma
itself.
So another way of writing
this is that the partition
function of the Ising model is
obtained by summing over all 2
to the n configurations
that I have.
If I have a lattice
of n sides, each side
can have two possibilities of
a kind of Hamiltonian, which
is basically some constant
plus h sum over i sigma i kind
of field that prefers one
side or the other side.
So it is an analog of a magnetic
field in this binary system.
And basically, I convert it from
a description that is overall
balanced to a description
overall sides.
And that's why I had put the
coordination number there.
It's kind of a
matter of convention.
And then a term that
prefers neighboring sites
to be aligned as
long as k positive.
So that's one
example of a model.
Another model that
we will also look at
is what I started to
draw at the beginning.
That is, at each site,
you have a vector.
And again, going in terms of
the pictures that we had before,
let's imagine that we have a
vector that has n components.
So SI is something
that is in RN.
And I will assume that the
magnitude of this vector
is one.
So essentially,
imagine that you have
a unit vector, and each
site that can rotate.
So if n equals to one, you
have essentially one component
vector.
Its square has to
be one, so the two
values that it can have
are plus one and minus one.
So the n equals to one case
is the Ising model again.
So this ON is a
generalization of the Ising
model to multiple components.
n equals to two corresponds
to a unit vector
that can take any angle
in two dimensions.
And that is usually
given the name xy model.
n equals to three is
something that maybe you
want to use to describe
magnetic ions in this lattice.
And classically, the direction
of this ion could be anywhere.
The spin of the
ion can be anywhere
on the surface of a sphere.
So that's three
components, and this model
is sometimes called
the Heisenberg model.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: In the
Ising model, what's
the correspondence between g
hat h hat j hat and g, h, and k?
PROFESSOR: Minus beta.
Yeah.
So maybe I should have written.
In order to take this-- if I
think of this as energy pair
bond, then in order to
get the Boltzmann weight,
I have to put a minus beta.
So I would have said
that this g, for example,
is minus beta g hat.
k is minus beta j hat.
And h is minus beta h hat.
So I should have
emphasized that.
What I meant by b--
actually, I wrote
b-- so what I should have
done here to be consistent,
let's write this as minus beta.
Thank you.
That was important.
If I described these b's
as being energies, then
minus beta times
that will be what
will go in the Boltzmann factor.
OK
So whereas these were examples
that we had more or less seen
their continuum version in
the Landau-Ginzburg model,
there are other symmetries
that get broken.
And things for which
we didn't discuss
what the corresponding
statistical field theory is.
A commonly used case
pertains to something
that's called a Potts model.
Where at each side
you have a variable,
let's call it SI,
that takes q values,
one, two, three,
all the way to q.
And I can write
what would appear
in the exponent
minus beta h to be
a sum over nearest neighbors.
And I can give some kind of
an interaction parameter here,
but a delta si sj.
So basically, what it says is
that on each side of a lattice,
you put a number.
Could be one, two,
three, up to q.
And if two neighbors are
the same, they like it,
and they gain some
kind of a weight.
That is, if k is positive,
encourages that to happen.
If the two neighbors
are different,
then it doesn't matter.
You don't gain energy,
but you don't really
care as to which one it is.
The underlying symmetry that
this has is permutation.
Basically, if you were to
permute all of these indices
consistently across the
lattice in any particular way,
the energy would not change.
So permutation symmetry
is what underlies this.
And again, if I look at the
case of two, then at each side,
let's say I have one or two.
And one one and two two are
things that gain energy.
One two or two one don't.
Clearly it is the same
as the Ising model.
So q equals to two is another
way of writing the Ising model.
Q equals to three is something
that we haven't seen.
So at each site, there
are three possibilities.
Actually, when I started at MIT
as a graduate student in 1979,
the project that I had
to do related to the q
equals to three Potts model.
Where did it come from?
Well, at that time,
people were looking
at surface of graphite,
which as you know,
has this hexagonal structure.
And then you can
absorb molecules
on top of that, such as,
for example, krypton.
And krypton would
want to come and sit
in the center of one
of these hexagons.
But its size was such
that once it sat there,
you couldn't occupy
any of these sides.
So the next one would have
to go, let's say, over here.
Now, it is possible to
subdivide this set of hexagons
into three sub lattices.
One, two, three, one,
two, three, et cetera.
Actually, I drew
this one incorrectly.
It would be sitting here.
And what happens is that
basically the agile particles
would order by occupying one of
three equivalent sublattices.
So the way that that order
got destroyed was then
described by the q equals to
three Potts universality class.
You can think of
something like q
equals to four that would
have a symmetry of a tetragon.
And so some structure that
is like a tetragon getting,
let's say, distorted in
some particular direction
would then have four equivalent
directions, et cetera.
So there's a whole set of other
types of universality classes
and symmetry breakings that
we did not discuss before.
And I just want
to emphasize that
what we discussed before does
not cover all possible symmetry
breakings.
It was just supposed to
show you an important class
and the technology
to deal with that.
But again, in this
particular system,
let's say you really wanted
to know at what temperature
the phase transition occurs,
as well as what potential phase
diagrams and
critical behavior is.
And then you would
say, well, even
if I could construct a
statistical field theory
and analyze it in
two dimensions,
and we've seen how
hard it is to go
below some other
critical dimension,
it doesn't tell me things about
phase diagrams, et cetera.
So maybe trying to understand
and deal with this lattice
model itself would tell
us more information.
Although about quantities that
are not necessarily inverse.
Depending on your
microscopic model,
you may try to introduce
more complicated systems,
such as inspired by quantum
mechanics, you can think
of something that
I'll call a spin S
model in which your SI
takes values from minus s,
minus s plus 1, all
the way to plus s.
There's 2s plus 1 possibilities.
And you can think of this
as components of, say,
a quantum spin of s
along the zed axis.
Write some kind of
Hamiltonian for this.
But as long as you deal
with things classically,
it turns out that
this kind of system
will not really have different
universality from the Ising
model.
So let's say we have
this lattice model.
Then what can we do?
So in the next
set of lectures, I
will describe some tools for
dealing with these models.
One set of approaches, the
one that we will start today,
has to do with the position
space renormalization group.
That is the approach
that we were following
for renormalization previously.
Dealt with going
to Fourier space.
We had this sphere,
hyper sphere.
And then we were basically
eliminating modes
at the edge of this
sphere in Fourier space.
We started actually by
describing the process
in real space.
So we will see
that in some cases,
it is possible to do a
renormalization group directly
on these lattice models.
Second thing is, it turns out
that as combinatorial problems,
some, but a very small
subset of these models,
are susceptible to
exact solutions.
Turns out that practically
all models in one dimension,
as we will start today,
one can solve exactly.
But there's one
prominent case, which
is the two dimensionalizing
model that one can also
solve exactly.
And it's a very
interesting solution
that we will also examine in, I
don't know, a couple of weeks.
Finally, there are
approximate schemes
that people have evolved for
studying these problems, where
you have series expansions
starting from limits, where
you know what is happening.
And one simple
example would be to go
to very high temperatures.
And at high temperatures,
essentially every degree
of freedom does what it wants.
So it's essentially a
zero dimensional problem
that you can solve.
And then you can start treating
interactions perturbatively.
So this is kind of
similar to the expansions
that we had developed in 8
333, the virial expansions,
et cetera, about
the ideal gas limit.
But now done on a system
that is a lattice,
and going to
sufficiently high order
that you can say something
about the phase transition.
There is another extreme.
In these systems, typically
the zero temperature state
is trivial.
It is perfectly ordered.
Let's say all the
spins are aligned.
And then you can start
expanding in excitations
around that state and
see whether eventually,
by including more
and more excitations,
you can see the phase transition
out of the ordered state.
And something that is actually
probably the most common use
of these models, but I
won't cover in class,
is to put them on the computer
and do some kind of a Monte
Carlo simulation,
which is essentially
a numerical way of trying to
generate configurations that
are governed by this weight.
And by changing the temperature
as it appears in that weight,
whether or not one can,
in the simulation, see
the phase transition happen.
So that's the change
in perspective
that I want you to have.
So the first thing
that we're going to do
is to do the number one here,
to do the position space
renormalization group of
one dimensional Ising model.
And the procedure that
I describe for you
is sufficiently general
that in fact you
can apply to any other
one dimensional model,
as long as you only have these
nearest neighbor interactions.
So here you have a lattice
that is one dimensional.
So you have a set
of sites one, two.
At some point, you have i,
i minus one, i plus one.
Let's say we call
the last one n.
So there are n sites.
There are going to be 2 to
the n possible configurations.
And your task is given
that at each site,
there's a variable
that is binary.
You want to calculate a
partition function, which
is a sum over all these 2
to the n configurations.
Of a weight that is
this e to the sum
over i B, the interaction
that couples SI and SI plus 1.
Maybe I should have
called this e hat.
And B is the thing that has
minus beta absorbed in it.
So notice that basically, the
way that I have written it,
one is interacting with two.
i minus one is
interacting with i.
i is interacting
with i plus one.
So I wrote the nearest
neighbor interaction
in this particular fashion.
We may or may not worry
about the last spin,
whether I want to
finish the series here,
or sometimes I will use
periodic boundary condition
and bring it back and couple
it to the first one, where
I have a ring.
So that's another possibility.
Doesn't really matter all
that much at this stage.
So this runs for i
going from one to n.
There are n degrees of freedom.
Now, renormalization
group is a procedure
by which I get rid of
some degrees of freedom.
So previously, I have
emphasized that what we did
was some kind of an averaging.
So we said that
let's say I could
do some averaging of
three sites and call
some kind of a representative
of those three.
Let's say that we
want to do a RG
by a factor of b equals to two.
So then maybe you say that
I will pick sigma i prime
and u sigma i to be sigma i
plus sigma i plus 1 over 2,
doing some kind of an average.
The problem with this choice
is that if the two spins are
both pluses, I will get plus.
If they're both minuses,
I will get minus.
If there is one plus and
one minus, I will get zero.
Why that is not
nice is that that
changes the structure
of the theory.
So I started with
binary variables.
I do this rescaling.
If I choose this scheme, I will
have three variables per site.
But I can insist upon keeping
two variables per site, as long
as I do everything
consistently and precisely.
So maybe I can say that
when this occurs, where
the two sites are different,
and the average would be zero,
I choose as tiebreaker
the left one.
So then I will
have plus or minus.
Now you can convince
yourself that if I do this,
and I choose always the
left one as tiebreaker,
the story is the same as
just keeping the left one.
So essentially, this kind of
averaging with a tiebreaker
is equivalent to getting
rid of every other spin.
And so essentially
what I can do is
to say that I call
a sigma i prime.
Now, in the new listing that I
have, this thing is no longer,
let's say, the tenth one.
It becomes the fifth one because
I removed half of things.
So sigma i prime is
really sigma 2i minus 1.
So basically, all the odd ones
I will call to be my new spins.
All the even ones I want to
get rid of, I'll call them SI.
So this is just a
renaming of the variables.
I did some handwaving
to justify.
Effectivity, all I did
was I broke this sum
into two sets of sums, but
I call sigma i prime and SI.
And each one of
them the index i,
rather than running from
1 to n in this new set,
the index i runs
from 1 to n over 2.
So what I have said,
agian, is very trivial.
I've said that the
original sum, I
bring over as a sum over
the odd spin, whose names
I have changed, and a
sum over even spins,
whose names I have called SI.
And I have an interaction,
which I can write as sum over i,
essentially running
from 1 to n over 2.
I start with the interaction
that involves sigma i
prime with si because
now each sigma i
prime is acting with
an s on one side.
And then there's
another interaction,
which is SI, and the next.
So essentially, I rename
things, and I regrouped bonds.
And the sum that was n terms
now n over 2 pairs of terms.
Nothing significant.
But the point is
that over here, I
can rewrite this as a
sum over sigma i prime.
And this is a product over
terms where within each term,
I can sum over the spin that
is sitting between two spins
that I'm keeping.
So I'm getting rid of this spin
that sits between spin sigma
i prime and sigma
i plus 1 prime.
Now, once I perform
this sum over SI here,
then what I will
get is some function
that depends on sigma i prime
and sigma i plus 1 prime.
And I can choose to
write that function as e
to the b prime sigma i
prime sigma i plus 1 prime.
And hence, the
partition function
after removing every
other spin is the same
as the partition function that
I have for the remaining spins
weighted with this b prime.
So you can see that I took the
original partition function
and recast it in
precisely the same form
after removing half of
the degrees of freedom.
Now, the original b
for the Ising model
is going to be parameterized
by g, h, and k.
So the b prime I
did parameterize.
So this, let's say, emphasizes
parameterized by g, h, k.
I can similarly
parameterize this
by g prime, h prime, k prime.
And how do I know that?
Because when I was
writing this, I
emphasized that this is
the most general form
that I can write down.
There is nothing else
other than this form
that I can write down for this.
So what I have essentially is
that this e to the b prime,
which is e to the g prime plus
h prime sigma i prime plus sigma
i plus 1 prime plus k
prime sigma i prime sigma
i plus 1 prime involves
these three parameters,
is obtained by summing over SI.
Let me just call it s being
minus plus 1 of e to the g plus
h sigma 1 sigma i prime plus
SI plus k sigma i prime SI
plus g plus kh sigma SI plus
sigma i plus 1 prime plus k SI
sigma i plus 1.
So it's an implicit
equation that
relates g prime, h prime,
k prime, to g, h, and k.
And in particular, just
to make the writing
of this thing explicit more
clearly, I will give names.
I will call e to the k to
the x, e to the h to by,
e to the g to bz.
And here, similarly,
I will write x prime e
to the k prime, y
prime e to the h prime,
and z prime is e to the g prime.
So now I just have
to make a table.
I have sigma i prime
sigma i plus 1 prime.
And here also I can
have values of s.
And the simplest possibility
here is I have plus plus.
Actually, let's put
this number further out.
So if both the sigma
primes are plus,
what do I have on
the left hand side?
I have e to the g
prime, which is z prime.
e to the 2h prime, which
is y prime squared.
e to the k prime,
which is x prime.
What do I have on
the left hand side?
On the left hand side, I
have two possible things
that I can put.
I can put s to be either
plus or s to be minus,
and I have to sum over
those two possibilities.
You can see that in all
cases, I have e to the 2g.
That's a trivial thing.
So I will always
have a z squared.
Irrespective of s, I
have two factors of e
to the h sigma prime.
OK, you know what happened?
I should've used--
since I was using
b, this factor of h over 2.
So I really should have
put here an h prime over 2,
and I should have
put here an h over 2
and h over 2 because the field
that was residing on the sites,
I am dividing half of it
to the right and half of it
to the left bond.
And since I'm writing things
in terms of the bonds,
that's how I should go.
So what I have here actually
is now one factor of i prime.
That's better.
Now, what I have on
the right is similarly
one factor of y
from the h's that
go with sigma 1
prime, sigma 2 prime.
And then if s is
plus, then you can
see that I will get two
factors of e to the k
because both bonds
will be satisfied.
Both bonds will be plus plus.
So I will get x squared,
and the contribution
to the h of the
intermediate bond s
is going to be 1e to the h.
So I will get x squared y.
Whereas if I put it the
intermediate sign for s
to be minus 1, then I have
two pluses at the end.
The one in the middle is minus.
So I would have two
dissatisfied factors of e
to the k becoming
e to the minus k.
So it's x to the minus 2.
And the field also
will give a factor of e
to the minus h or y inverse.
So there are four
possibilities here.
The next one is minus minus.
z prime will stay the way it is.
The field has switched sign.
So this becomes y prime inverse.
But since both of them
are minus-- minus,
minus-- the k factor
is satisfied and happy.
Gives me x prime because
it's e to the plus k.
On the right hand side, I
will always get the z squared.
The first factor
becomes the inverse.
Now, s plus 1 is a
plus site, plus spin,
that is sandwiched
between two minus spins.
So there are two unhappy bonds.
This gives me x to the minus 2.
Why the spin is pointing in
the direction of the field.
So there's the y here.
And here I will get x
squared and y inverse
because now I have
three negative signs.
So all the k's are happy.
There's the next one,
which is plus and minus.
Plus and minus, we can see that
the contribution to the field
vanishes.
Because sigma i prime and plus
sigma i plus 1 prime are zero.
I will still get z,
the contribution,
because plus and minus,
the bond between them
gives me e to the minus k prime.
I have here z squared.
There is no overall contribution
of y for the same reason
that there was nothing here.
But from s, I will get a
factor of y plus y inverse.
And there's no
contribution for x
because I have a
plus and a minus.
And if the spin is either
plus or minus in the middle,
there will be one satisfied
and one dissatisfied bond.
Again, by symmetry,
the other configuration
is exactly the same.
So while I had four
configuration, and hence
four things to match, the
last two are the same.
And that's consistent
with my having
three variables, x prime, y
prime, and z prime, to solve.
So there are three equations
and three variables.
Now, to solve these equations,
we can do several things.
Let's, for example, multiply
all four equations together.
What do we get on
the left hand side?
There are two x's, two
inverse x's, y, and inverse y,
but four factors of z.
So I get z prime to
the fourth factor.
On the other side, I
will get z to the eight,
and then the product
of those four factors.
I can divide one, equation
one, by equation two.
What do I get?
The x's cancel.
So I will get y prime squared.
On the other side,
divide these two.
I will get y squared.
x squared y plus x
squared y inverse,
x minus 2y plus x2 minus--
yeah, x2 y inverse.
And finally, to get the equation
for x prime, what I can do
is I can multiply 1 and
2, divide by 3 and 4.
And if I do that, on
the left hand side
I will get x prime
to the fourth.
And on the right
hand side, I will
get x squared y plus x
to the minus 2 y inverse
x minus 2y x squared y inverse
divided by y plus y inverse
squared.
So I can take the log of
these equations, if you like,
to get the recurrence
relations for the parameters.
For example, taking the
log of that equation,
you can see that I
will get g prime.
From here, I would get
2g plus some function.
There's some delta g
that depends on k and h.
If I do the same
thing here, you can
see that I will
get an h prime that
is h plus some function
from the log of this
that depends on k and h.
And finally, I will get k
prime some function of k and h.
This parameter g is
not that important.
It's basically an
overall constant.
The way that we started
it, we certainly
don't expect it to modify
phase diagrams, et cetera.
And you can see that it never
affects the equations that
govern h and k, the
two parameters that
give the relative weight of
different configurations.
Whether you are in a ferromagnet
or a disordered state
is governed by these
two parameters.
And indeed, we can ignore this.
Essentially, what it amounts to
is as follows, that every time
I remove some of the
spins, I gradually
build a contribution
to my free energy.
Because clearly, once
I have integrated out
over all of the energies, what I
will have will be the partition
function.
Its log would be
the free energy.
And actually, we encountered
exactly the same thing
when we were doing
momentum space RG.
There was always, as a
result of the integration,
some contribution that I
call delta f that I never
looked at because, OK, it's
part of the free energy
but does not govern
the relative weights
of the different configurations.
So these are really
the two things
that we need to focus on.
Now, if we did things
correctly and these
are correct equations, had
I started in the subspace
where h equals to zero,
which had up-down symmetries,
I could have changed all of
my sigmas to minus sigma,
and for h equals to zero, the
energy would not have changed.
So a check that we
did things correctly
is that if h equals to zero,
then h prime has to be zero.
So let's see.
If h equals to zero
or y is equal to one,
well if y is equal
to one, you can
see that those two factors in
the numerator and denominator
are exactly the same.
And so y prime stays to one.
So this check has
been performed.
So if I am on h equals to
zero on the subspace that
has symmetry, then I have only
one parameter, this k or x.
And so on this space, the
recursion relation that I have
is that x prime
to the fourth is x
squared plus x to
the minus 2 squared.
I think I made a mistake here.
No, it's correct.
y plus y inverse.
OK, but y is one.
So this is divided by
2 squared, which is 4.
But let me double check
so that I don't go-- yeah.
So this is correct.
So I can write it in terms
of x being e to the k.
So what I have here
is e to the 4k prime.
I have here e to the 2k plus e
to the minus 2k divided by 2,
which is hyperbolic
cosine of 2k, squared.
So what I will get is k
prime is 1/2 log hyperbolic
cosine of 2k.
Now, k is a parameter
that we are changing.
As we make k stronger,
presumably things
are more coupled to each
other and should go more
towards order.
As k goes towards zero,
basically the spins
are independent.
They can do whatever they like.
So it kind of makes
sense that there
should be a fixed point at
zero corresponding to zero
correlation length.
And let's check that.
So if k is going to zero--
it's very small-- then
k prime is 1/2 log hyperbolic
cosine of a small number,
is roughly 1 plus that
small number squared over 2.
There's a series like that.
Log of 1 plus a small
number is a small number.
So this becomes 4k
squared over 2 over 2.
It's k squared.
So it says that if I, let's say,
start with a k that is 1/10,
my k prime would be
1/100 and then 1/10,000.
So basically, this
is a fixed point
that attracts everything to it.
Essentially, what
it says is you may
have some weak
amount of coupling.
As you go and look at the spins
that are further and further
apart, the effective coupling
between them is going to zero.
And the spins that
are further apart
don't care about each other.
They do whatever they like.
So that all makes
physical sense.
Well, we are really
interested in this other end.
What happens at k
going to infinity?
We can kind of look
at this equation.
Or actually, look at this
equation, also doesn't matter.
But here, maybe it's clearer.
So I have e to the 4k prime.
And this is going to
be dominated by this.
This is e to the 2k.
e to the minus 2k is very small.
So it's going to
be approximately
e to the 4k divided by 4.
So what I have out here
is that k is very large.
k prime is roughly
k, but then smaller
by a factor that
is 1/2 of log 2.
So we try to take two spins that
are next to each other, couple
them with a very strong k.
Let's say a million,
10 million, whatever.
And then I look at spins
that are too further apart.
They're still very strongly
coupled, but slightly less.
It's a million minus log 2.
So it very, very gradually
starts to move away from here.
But then as it kind of goes
further, it kind of speeds up.
What it says is that it is true.
At infinity, you
have a fixed point.
But that fixed
point is unstable.
And even if you have very
strong but finite coupling,
because things are finite, as
you go further and further out,
the spins become less
and less correlated.
This, again, is another
indication of the statement
that a one dimensional
system will not order.
So one thing that you
can do to sort of make
this look slightly better, since
we have the interval from zero
to infinity, is to
change variables.
I can ask what does
tang of k prime do?
So tang k prime is e to the
2k prime minus 1 divided by
e to the 2k prime plus 1.
You write e to the 2k's
in terms of this variable.
At the end of the day,
a little bit of algebra,
you can convince yourself
that the recursion relation
for tang k has a
very simple form.
The new tang k is simply the
square of the old tang k.
If I plot things as
a function of tang k
that runs between zero
and one, that fixed point
that was at infinity
gets mapped into one,
and the flow is
always towards here.
There is no other
fixed point in between.
Previously, it wasn't
clear from the way
that I had written whether
potentially there's
other fixed points
along the k-axis.
If you write it as t
prime tang is t squared,
where t stands for tang,
clearly the only fixed points
are at zero and one.
But now this also
allows us to ask
what happens if
you also introduce
the field direction,
h, in this space.
Now, one thing to
check is that if you
start with k equals to zero,
that is independent spins,
you look at the equation here.
k equals to 0 corresponds
to x equals to one.
This factor drops out.
You see y prime is equal to y.
So if you have no
coupling, there
is no reason why the
magnetic field should change.
So essentially, this entire line
corresponds to fixed points.
Every point here
is a fixed point.
And we can show
that, essentially,
if you start along
field zero, you go here.
If you start along different
values of the field,
you basically go to
someplace along this line.
And all of these flows
originate, if you go and plot
them, from back here
at this fixed point
that we identified before
at h equals to zero.
So in order to find out what is
happening along that direction,
all we need to do is to go and
look at x going to infinity.
With x going to
infinity, you can
see that y prime squared, the
equation that we have for y,
y prime squared is y squared.
And then there's this fraction.
Clearly, the terms that are
proportional to x squared
will overwhelm
those proportional
to x to the minus 2.
So I will get a
y and a y inverse
from the numerator
and denominator.
And so this goes
like y to the fourth.
Which means that in the vicinity
of this point, what you have is
that h prime is 2h.
So this, again, is
irrelevant direction.
And here, you are flowing
in this direction.
And the combination
of these two really
justifies the kind of flows
that I had shown you before.
So essentially, in the
one dimensional model,
you can start with any
microscopic set of k and h's
that you want.
As you rescale, you essentially
go to independent spins
with an effective
magnetic field.
So let's say we start with
very close to this fixed point.
So we had a very
large value of k.
I expect if I have
a large value of k,
neighboring spins are
really close to each other.
I have to go very far before,
if I have a patch of pluses,
I can go over to a
patch of minuses.
So there's a large
correlation length
in the vicinity of this point.
And that correlation
length is a function
of our parameters k and h.
Now, the point is that
the recursion relation
that I have for k does not look
like the type of recursions
that I had before.
This one is fine because I can
think of this as my usual h
prime is b to the yh h, where
here I'm clearly dealing
with a b equals to two, and so
I can read off my yh to be one.
But the recursion
relation that I have for k
is not of that form.
But who said that I
choose k as the variable
that I put over here?
I have been doing all of
these manipulations going
from k to x, et cetera.
One thing that behaves
nicely, you can see,
is a variable if I
call e to the minus k
prime is square root
of 2 e to the minus k.
At k equals to infinity,
this is something
that goes to zero on both ends.
But if its k is
large but not finite,
it says that on
the rescaling, it
changes by a factor of root 2.
So if I say, well,
what is c as a function
of the magnetic field,
rather than writing k,
I will write it as
e to the minus k.
It's just another way
of writing things.
Well, I know that under
one step of RG, all
my length scales have
shrunk by a factor of two.
So this is twice the c that
I should write down with 2h
and root 2 e to the minus k.
So I just related the
correlation length
before and after one
step of RG, starting
from very close to this point.
And for these two
factors, 2 and root 2,
I use the results that
I have over there.
And this I can keep doing.
I can keep iterating this.
After l steps of
RG, this becomes 2
to the l, c of 2
to the lh, and 2
to the l over 2
e to the minus k.
I iterate this sufficiently
so that I have moved away
from this fixed point, where
everything is very strongly
correlated.
And so that means
I move, let's say,
until this number is something
that is of the order of one.
Could be 2.
Could be 1/2.
I really don't care.
But the number of
iterations, the number
of rescalings by a
factor of two that I
have to do in order to achieve
this, is when 2 to the l
is of the order of e to the k.
e to the 2k, sorry.
And if I do that, I
find that c should
be e to the 2k some
function of h e to the 2k.
So let's say I am
at h equals to zero.
And I make the strength of the
interaction between neighbors
stronger and stronger.
If I asked you, how does
the correlation length,
how does the size of the patches
that are all plus and minus
change as k becomes
stronger and stronger?
Well, RG tells you that
it goes in this fashion.
In the problem
set that you have,
you will solve the problem
exactly by a different method
and get exactly this form.
What else?
Well, we said that one of the
characteristics of a system
is that the free
energy has a singular
part as a function
of the variables
that we have that is related
to the correlation length
to the power d.
In this case, we
have d equals to one.
So the statement is
that the singular part
of the free energy, as you
approach infinite coupling
strength, behaves
as e to the minus 2k
some other function
of h, e to the 2k.
Once you have a
function such as this,
you can take two
derivatives with respect
to the field to get
the susceptibility.
So the susceptibility would
go like two derivatives
of the free energy with
respect to the field.
You can see that each derivative
brings forth a factor of e
to the 2k.
So two derivatives will bring
a factor of e to the 2k,
if I evaluate it at
h equals to zero.
So the statement is that
if I'm at zero field,
and I put on a small
infinitesimal magnetic field,
it tends to overturn
all of the spins
in the direction of the field.
And the further you are
close to k to infinity,
there are larger responses
that you would see.
The susceptibility
of the response
diverges as k goes to infinity.
So in some sense, this model
does not have phase transition,
but it demonstrates some
signatures of the phase
transition, such as
diverging correlation length
and diverging
susceptibility if you
go to very, very strong
nearest neighbor coupling.
There is one other
relationship that we had.
That is, the susceptibility
is an integral
in d dimension over
the correlation length,
which we could say
in one dimension--
well, actually, let's
write it in d dimension.
e to the minus x
over c divided by x.
We introduce an exponent,
eta, to describe
the decay of correlations.
So this would generally behave
like c to the 2 minus eta.
Now, in this case, we see that
both the correlation length
and susceptibility diverge with
the same behavior, e to the 2k.
They're proportional
to each other.
So that immediately
tells me that for the one
dimensional system
that we are looking at,
eta is equal to one.
And if I substitute back
here, so eta is one,
the dimension is one,
and the two cancels.
Essentially, it says that
the correlation length
in one dimension have a
pure exponential decay.
They don't have this
sub leading power load
that you would have
in higher dimensions.
So when you do
things exactly, you
will also be able
to verify that.
So all of the predictions
of this position space
RG method that we can carry out
in this one dimensional example
very easily, you can
also calculate and obtain
through the method that
is called transfer matrix,
and is the subject
of the problem set
that was posted yesterday.
Also, you can see that
this approach will
work for any system
in one dimension.
All I really need to ensure is
that the b that I write down
is sufficiently
general to include
all possible interactions that
I can write between two spins.
Because if I have some
subset of those interactions,
and then I do this procedure
that I have over here
and then take the
log, there's no reason
why that would not
generate all things that
are consistent with symmetry.
So you really have to
put all possible terms,
and then you will get
all possible terms here,
and there would be a recursion
relation that would relate.
You can do this very easily, for
example, for the Potts model.
For the continuous spin systems,
it becomes more difficult.
Now let's say briefly as to why
we can solve things exactly,
let's say, for the one
dimensionalizing model
by this procedure.
But this procedure we cannot
do in higher dimensions.
So let's, for example, think
that we have a square lattice.
Just generalize what we
had to two dimensions.
And let's say that we want
to eliminate this spin
and-- well, let's see,
what's the best way?
Yeah, we want to eliminate
a checkerboard of spins.
So we want to eliminate
half of the spins.
Let's say the white
squares on a checkerboard.
And if I were to eliminate these
spins, like I did over here,
I should be able to
generate interactions
among spins that are left over.
So you say, fine.
Let's pick these four spins.
Sigma 1, sigma 2,
sigma 3, sigma 4,
that are connected
to this spin, s,
that is sitting in the middle,
that I have to eliminate.
So let's also stay
in the space where
h equals to zero,
just for simplicity.
So the result of
eliminating that is
I have to do a sum over s.
I have e to the-- let's say
the original interaction is k,
and s is coupled by these bonds
to sigma 1, sigma 2, sigma 3,
sigma 4.
Now, summing over the
two possible values of s
is very simple.
It just gives me e to
the k times the sum plus
e to the minus k, that sum.
So it's the same thing as 2
hyperbolic cosine of k, sigma
1 plus sigma 2 plus
sigma 3 plus sigma 4.
We say good.
I had something like
that, and I took a log
so that I got the k prime.
So maybe I'll do something
like a recasting of this,
and maybe a recasting of this
will give me some constant,
will give me some
kind of a k prime,
and then I will have sigma
1, sigma 2, sigma 2, sigma 3,
sigma 3, sigma 4,
sigma 4, sigma 1.
But you immediately see that
that cannot be the entire
story.
Because there is really
no ordering among sigma 1,
sigma 2, sigma 3, sigma 4.
So clearly, because of
the symmetries of this,
you will generate also sigma 1
sigma 3 plus sigma 2 sigma 4.
That is, eliminating this
spin will generate for you
interactions among
these, but also
interactions that go like this.
And in fact, if you
do it carefully,
you'll find that you will also
generate an interaction that
is product of all four spins.
You will generate something
that involves all of the force.
So basically, because
of the way of geometry,
et cetera, that you have
in higher dimensions,
there is no trick that
is analogous to what
we could do in one dimension
where you would eliminate
some subset of spins and not
generate longer and longer
range interactions, interactions
that you did not have.
You could say, OK, I
will start including
all of these
interactions and then
have a higher, larger
parameter space.
But then you do
something else, you'll
find that you need to
include further and further
neighboring interactions.
So unless you do some kind of
termination or approximation,
which we will do
next time, then there
is no way to do this exactly
in higher dimensions.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I mean, are you
putting any sort of weight
on the fact that, for
example, sigma 1 and sigma 3
are farther apart than
sigma 1 and sigma 2,
or are we using taxi cab
distances on this lattice?
PROFESSOR: Well, we are
thinking of an original model
that we would like
to solve, in which
I have specified that
things are coupled only
to nearest neighbors.
So the ones that correspond
to sigma 1, sigma 3,
are next nearest neighbors.
They're certainly farther
apart on the lattice.
You could say, well,
there's some justification,
if these are ions
and they have spins,
to have some weaker interaction
that goes across here.
There has to be some
notion of space.
I don't want to couple everybody
to everybody else equivalently.
But if I include this,
then I have further more
complicated Hamiltonian.
And when I do RG,
I will generate
an even more
complicated Hamiltonian.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Question is, suppose
I have a square lattice.
Let's go here.
And the suggestion
is, why don't I
eliminate all of
the spins over here,
maybe all of the
spins over here?
So the problem is that I
will generate interactions
that not only go like this, but
interactions that go like this.
So the idea of what happens is
that imagine that there's these
spins that you're eliminating.
As long as there's paths that
connect the spins that you're
eliminating to any
other spin, you
will generate that
kind of couple.
Again, the reason that the
one dimensional model works
is also related to
its exact solvability
by this transfer matrix method.
So I will briefly mention
that in the last five minutes.
So for one dimensional
models, the partition function
is a sum over whatever
degree of freedom you have.
Could be Ising, Potts,
xy, doesn't matter.
But the point is
that the interaction
is a sum of bonds that connect
one site to the next site.
I can write this as a product of
e to the b of SI and SI plus 1.
Now, I can regard
this entity-- let's
say I have the Potts
model q values.
This is q possible values.
So there are q squared possible
values of the interaction.
And there is q squared
possible values
of this Boltzmann weight.
I can regard that
as a matrix, but I
can write in this fashion.
And so what you
have over there, you
can see is effectively you have
s1, ts2, s2, ts3, and so forth.
And if I use periodic boundary
condition like the one
that I indicated there so
that the last one is connected
to the first one, and then I
do a sum over all of these s's,
this is just the
product of two matrices.
So this is going to become, when
I sum over s2, s1 t squared s3
and so forth.
You can see that
the end result is
trace of the matrix t
raised to the power of n.
Now, the trace you can
calculate in any representation
of the matrix.
If you manage to find
the representation where
t is diagonal, then
the trace would
be sum over alpha
lambda alpha to the n,
where these lambdas are the
eigenvalues of this matrix.
And if n is very large,
the thermodynamic
limit that we are
interested, it will
be dominated by the
largest eigenvalue.
Now, if I write this for
something like Potts model
or any of the spin models that
I had indicated over there,
you can see that all
elements of this matrix
being these Boltzmann
weights are plus, positive.
Now, there's a theorem called
Frobenius's theorem, which
states that if you have a
matrix, all of its eigenvalues
are positive, then the largest
eigenvalues is non-degenerate.
So what that means is that if
this matrix is characterized
by a set of parameters, like
our k's, et cetera, and I
change that parameter,
k, well the eigenvalue
is obtained by looking
at a single matrix.
It doesn't know
anything about that.
The only way that the
eigenvalue can become singular
is if two eigenvalues
cross each other.
And since Frobenius's
theorem does not allow that,
you conclude that this
largest eigenvalue
has to be a perfectly nice
analytical function of all
of the parameters that go into
constructing this Hamiltonian.
And that's a mathematical way
of saying that there is no phase
transition for one dimensional
model because you cannot have
a crossing of eigenvalues, and
there is no singularity that
can take place.
Now, an interesting then
question or caveat to that
comes from the very question
that was asked over here.
What if I have, let's say,
a two dimensional model,
and I regard it essentially
as a complicated one
dimensional model in
which I have a complicated
multi-variable
thing over one side,
and then I can go through this
exact same procedure over here
also?
And then I would have to
diagonalize this huge matrix.
So if this is l, it would be a
2 to the l by 2 to the l matrix.
And you may naively
think that, again,
according to
Frobenius's theorem,
there should be no
phase transition.
Now, this is exactly what
Lars Onsager did in order
to solve the two
dimensionalizing model.
He constructed this matrix
and was clever enough
to diagonalize it and show
that in the limit of l going
to infinity, then the
Frobenius's theorem
can and will be violated.
And so that's something
that we will also
discuss in some of
our future lectures.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: But it won't
be violated in the one
dimensional case, even
if n goes to infinity?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because
n only appears over here.
Lambda max is a perfectly
analytic function.